her latest book is adios America the
left's plan to turn our country into a
third-world hellhole she's on to us and
Coulter's over here and holder Vanna
Bullock considering that's right okay
well thank you as always for coming into
the Lions Den I know you know they're
predisposed not to like what you're
gonna say and tonight they're really not
like you know like you you wrote a book
about immigration yes and and you know
we're gonna don't we're gonna get to you
very soon because I asked if you would
mind if we if we book the congressman
with you and you're okay with it I said
fantastic fantastic okay you have an
honest disagreement so um it's good
publicity that Donald Trump was sort of
saying what you were saying yeah
Mexicans rapists beheading yeah um but
what I what I find odd is that you say
in the book over and over that it's very
hard to get facts to get actual stats
and yet you come to conclusions like
they're rapists um well I described that
in in the chapter this book this wasn't
going to be the original book this was
immigration it's just going to be a
couple of chapters and then when the
information wasn't there
I drove me crazy for one thing I go
through how the information is being
hidden both by the government and by by
the media but there are ancillary facts
for example as you can see in that
chapter New York state keeps a list of
prisoners by nationality and and there
it is you have a thousand Dominicans you
have one Dane and he's probably a Muslim
you we have the Most Wanted but we're
not on the border with Denmark there are
less Danes here well but we don't
we don't need to take people just
because they're on our border we didn't
used to take people just because they
live within walking distance we used to
have an immigration policy where we
would choose the best in the world and
that was changed this is a fairly recent
policy we would choose the whitest in
the world that's it's your audience um
no we wouldn't but we look the pre-1970
immigrants were more educated made more
money were more likely to buy houses and
30% of them went home now no one goes
home they go on welfare and they are far
more likely to be on welfare than the
native population I think of Nations
policies should be concerned with the
people already here and that includes
the immigrants who came last year and
the year before it should be people who
will live here benefit not to become the
you know battered women's shelter of the
world we're betting man
the hardest cases and um you know the
the wifebeaters and then don't single
mother with 8 kids get where but where
but again I I don't feel these
assertions are borne out by stats
because they have stats from different
governmental departments like you say
there are actually 30 million illegals
whereas any other department I can find
well they're all well same number though
they're going by the census figures so
if you take the census figures it
doesn't matter who looks at the census
figures they're going to give you the
same number it's been 11 million for a
decade and I explained in the book what
where that number comes from and I think
it comes from more reliable source but
where do you get from 12 to 30 I'll be
happy to explain it I think it's easier
to read it was a couple of bear stearns
analysts and they said their Stearns
that's a financial group isn't it why
yes it is and advising something about
something more important than some dumb
census report their money so they said
look this is crazy people who have
trekked thousands of miles left their
families behind broken laws stolen
social security cards are not going to
be filling out government surveys and in
fact California did a survey of
in Hispanic communities asking out here
are you illegal did you fill out the
survey there was a backup service survey
and only 40 percent damns answer that
survey so it's silly to think that we're
getting honest answers here so what the
what the bear stearns analysts looked at
was remittances to mexico they looked at
school enrollments they looked at
housing permits and they came to the
conclusion that was 20 million that was
back in 2005 then the two famous
Pulitzer prize-winning journalist
Barlett and steel very famous for Time
magazine and for you look up they have
their own Wikipedia page just themselves
they spent a year investigating and they
said we're getting three million a year
so my 30 million estimate that was in
2006 my 30 million estimate is a very
low estimate let's say it was only 1
million a year since 2005 on the minimum
price I'm not Hispanic
okay so I bet I've read everywhere that
actually the net immigration from Mexico
in the last seven years has been zero
but because our economy got worse
there's got better they went Mexican
women used to have seven children and
now they have two I think that would
make a big difference
Don so let's say everything you say is
true which it isn't
and there is my little mark aside it's
irrelevant the point at issue is should
America's immigration policy be used to
benefit the people already here or
should it be benefiting Pakistani
pushcart operators illiterate in their
own language never mind ours who come
here go on welfare commit terrorism
engage in crimes all right why why
wouldn't you look out across the world
like a sports team does and try to get
the creme de la creme not like this
audience we don't want these people
you gotta give it to her she ain't
afraid gotta give her that but she's
also but she's also wrong okay now is
also what's their rebuttal look 30
million 12 million big difference I
would just say one thing
worried about the 50 million Latinos in
the United States of America that are
here legally worried about that's at the
moment who care and who care deeply
because of many of the people that you
refer to as murderers and rapists and
criminals and people that are on welfare
are their aunts their uncles their
classmates their work they work with
them these are people they care about so
what I think that aunt Coulter is
actually doing along with Donald Trump
is that they're just revving up you know
it's like a Latino registration machine
because every time they say these things
I say this quite easily a million
Latinos turn 18 every year in the United
States of America and and they're all
American citizens of the United States
and for and here's what happened and
here's what happens they become the
basis of the new American Coalition in
American political coalition that is
young people that is Latinos it is
immigrants it's african-americans it's
Asians it's gay people it's people to
care about the economy and it's people
that care about the environment and look
you're never going to take the White
House with this kind of politics ever
again because there's a
all right but that didn't exactly answer
her question attempt to answer yes your
question is colter because i think one
of the things that we have to do in this
country is to stop lying we were earlier
talking and touched on the issue of
slavery ever since the forcible removal
of millions of African Americans from
chattel slavery this country has been
importing new slave labor that's right
because this country wants and runs and
it's fuelled by cheap labor with Roberto
Ricans whether it was people we drew
from Mexico to come here and continue to
do so because the people who are on your
side big fart big agranov a big
agriculture the big corporate interests
who want people to crochet does say that
agree with you okay well once we bring
people here people's family members
peoples whose families are born here are
American my both my parents are
immigrants so I take great exception to
any kind of negative characterization of
them I had one come from Africa my
mother came from the Caribbean when they
came here they came for the same reason
than everyone does for opportunity for
education and when they're contributing
to our society and they have a child
here like me I'm a first-generation
American and I'm fully American despite
the fact that both my parents were born
outside okay
also doesn't answer my point though it
buttresses one of the main points I am
making you know this is cheap labor and
particularly then why isn't the book
called thugs
well how corporate Republicans are
estimating the middle okay in fact as I
told Scott that's the one error in the
book the title I don't argue you ever
read the book online at it every time
but I'll turn on the plane in the hot
tub once I once trade it is far more of
an attack on Republicans on big business
on the Chamber of Commerce yes is on I
agree
um I didn't want to subject at all but
if I listen to all the people who are
trying to show your dirty into a third
world hellhole I bet it would go on to
the back page let me ask yes let me ask
you something look the question is still
yeah right here bad boy then why should
a mirror and a care that other people of
the world are happy they should care
about the ones that are here and now
including you and all the fruits you eat
all the vegetables you eat they are all
picked by foreign lay back it works but
can i connect the connect connect this
is no deal at all not even beyond like a
master a mulligan alex serabian cannot
strawberries tomatoes but then you know
they are not so take immunity by machine
you don't even cross country with their
family or a cheater all right you know
where it is
but you were not recognized or justice
recognized yes we're not gonna you know
what this is over comes over and I
couldn't answer yeah I know I know we're
not going to talk over each other okay
so we do on this show
I'll take so I will take over yeah I
don't just asked you two more questions
and then we'll get onto the Pope one
Geraldo's you a great friend
is he okay with this book um yes I said
something very nice about the Puerto
Ricans they made our country I pointed
it out to one all right and also we
didn't in other words we were need 30
million Mexicans we already had African
Americans and I mean african-americans
not immigrants and we already had the
Puerto Ricans and what about I'm just
stating what I don't need the 1965 act
for all this vibrant we're getting is
we're getting I'm gonna cram what about
air use your imaginary friend Jesus
Christ I mean would he be okay with this
attitude about about this yes of course
you don't have to take homeless people
to sleep in your bed to prove you're a
Christian this is our home
seems like he would like that okay
you